Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Astronaut Mike Hopkins ran around the world.
Sort of.
During a 12 mile run on a treadmill the space
station had orbited the Earth and traveled
more than 25 thousand miles.
What the FAK.....the facts and knowledge on
the daily life of Astronauts.
With a new sunrise every 90 minutes interrupting
their natural circadian rhythms along with
loud engine noises, and floating in microgravity
it's much harder to sleep in space than on
Earth.
Astronauts have to tether sleeping bags to
the ground, ceiling, or wall so they don't
float around and bump into things.
Aboard the International Space Station, crew
members have individual sleeping quarters
that are well ventilated so they're not surrounded
by the carbon dioxide they're exhaling.
Ear plugs, sleep masks, and sleeping pills
are used to combat the unusual feeling of
sleeping without gravity, yet still astronauts
get 30 to 60 minutes less sleep per night
on average compared to when they're on Earth.
Since water won't naturally fall into a drain
system, astronauts get creative when it comes
to showering.
Like taking a sponge bath where they moisten
a cloth using warm packaged water with soap
already mixed in, rubbing themselves down,
and drying off with a towel.
Sometimes they can shower in a plastic cylinder
that goes from floor to ceiling to prevent
water from floating away.
For their hair there is a rinseless shampoo
that is applied, rubbed in, and wiped off
with a towel.
Because there's no washer or dryer - clothes
are disposable.
Shirts, socks, and underwear are changed every
day or two and pants once a week.
That's just inside the stabilized interior,
if they're required to go out into space it
gets a lot more complicated.
Space suits must protect from a pressurized
atmosphere, provide oxygen, allow sight and
movement, protect from radiation and micro
meteoroids, and do all of this while keeping
the human body at a comfortable temperature.
There are 25 steps to take when getting into
and out of the 13 layer, 280 pound, 12 million
dollar suit referred to as an EMU.
Astronauts select their food menus about 5
months before taking flight.
Those selections are sent in for review and
analyzed for nutritional content because nutrition
is vital to the health of the crew.
Each is provided with three meals a day plus
snacks with two days worth of emergency meals
per person if needed.
Aboard the shuttles and at the ISS foods come
prepared in four ways: thermostabalized, rehydratable,
natural form, and irradiated.
They're stored in special packaging to prevent
anything from floating around and even condiments
like salt and pepper are suspended in liquid
to prevent particles from floating away.
For exercise there's a treadmill, stationary
bike, or resistance training.
Two and a half hours a day are devoted to
physical fitness.
One reason this is so important is because
astronauts lose plasma throughout the body
because body fluids move around in microgravity
and exercise is proven to increase the amount
of plasma.
When they're not working out or walking in
space they stay entertained by watching TV
streamed from Earth, working on the computer,
and reading.
Along with doing experiments on how things
work in microgravity.
Toilets are equipped with footholds and both
men and women can urinate standing up with
the aid of a funnel.
When its time to sit down astronauts pull
a bar over their laps like when riding a roller
coaster that fastens to their thighs.
To avoid anything floating around, space toilets
use flowing air instead of water to flush.
When astronauts return from spacewalks and
remove their helmets there's a lingering odor
of what space smells like left on their suits
and it's described to be similar to burnt
metal.
I'm gonna leave you with this - who is the
only US President to ever be present during
the launch of a shuttle?
Before we go here's last video's winner.
Leave your answers in the comments below - be
sure to subscribe for more Vsauce2.
And as always - thanks for watching.